this is the National Hockey
League's first time down under
Aussie people are great sports fanatics
luckily for us we get to see that
firsthand we'd love to turn a bunch of
Australians into hockey fans [Music]
the animal you want to see kangaroo yeah for sure
we got the Vegemite interesting here it's
a pretty unique taste to meet another
professional from another sport it's always fun
get to know a little bit about their sport it's
a middle finger boss names that's it I still love
it still watch every tournament on TV yeah it was
super cool for me once a lifetime experience
and that's what's really fun about this trip
[Music]
three a game has been played not only in
Australia but in the southern hemisphere
with a shot Penny scores dancing Cooley scores
what a goal by the youngster that is something
you cannot teach ing that look and he'll score the
horn ends game one here in Melbourne 5-3 Arizona
welcome again everybody to game two of this
weekend set the building will be full again as the
Aussies continue to show their support a chance
and a goal Barrett Hayton [Applause] he scores
shot score
Kings defeat Arizona the coyote
salute the crowd here the king
salute the crowd it has been fantastic [Applause]